new poll numbers give presumptive
democratic nominee joe biden a lead in
north carolina
and georgia they are states that voted
republican in the last two presidential
elections
our cbs news battleground tracker puts
biden four points ahead of president
trump in north carolina
and one point ahead in georgia where
will likely be a tight race again
biden is unlikely to announce his vice
presidential pick this week but he is
expected to narrow that list down
cbs news political correspondent ed
o'keefe joins us with more on all of
this
ed we mentioned north carolina and
georgia but i want to talk about
texas here for a minute you have some
new reporting on this this is a big
organized play by the biden campaign in
texas
certainly bigger than usual jeff yes
good morning you know a democrat hasn't
won texas since 1976 when fellow
southerner jimmy carter did it but in
this case the biting campaign has seen
enough
over the summer to suggest that they
have a real shot at that state's 38
electoral votes they're putting a team
in place
to try to win the state again that's
still a big if
it is a challenge obviously part of this
could just be tactical
in hopes of having the trump campaign
and republicans spend more money in
texas
and divert that money away from other
battleground states but the way the
biden team now sees it
they consider texas a battleground
alongside north carolina georgia
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
arizona all those other places in play
how much impact does the vp pick have
in these battleground states you know
traditionally jeff
it doesn't have much of an impact the
only time recently where it had an
adverse impact on the candidate probably
was
and actually not probably definitely in
some cases with sarah palin back in 2008
because there were concerns
over the course of the campaign that she
perhaps was not ready for the role and
that john mccain
had miscalculated but usually they're
not really there to
to cause any real big bump or any real
decline in the ratings the hope here
however
is that his pick can help inspire the
democratic base the younger voters women
minorities
that biden is going to need to turn out
and there is extra sensitivity of course
this time
because biden given his 77 years
would be the oldest man elected
president conceivably there is
he has not committed necessarily to
running for a second term
so whoever he picks could in essence be
put in place
to succeed him or to run in 2024
should he take a pass so a lot more
sensitivity and interest in this
and of course the fact that he has vowed
to pick a woman joe biden
first said it was going to happen this
week that's now been moved back
until next week correct
the announcement is now expected next
week yes but we expect that
in the coming few days here he's going
to start interviewing some of these
potential picks
himself we don't know if that's going to
be in person at a social distance or
whether it's going to be over zoom
but it is expected that he will spend
the next few days now trying to sort
this
out you know next week let's put it this
way two weeks from today jeff i'm
scheduled to be in milwaukee for the
start of the democratic convention
whatever that's going to look like
and so the hope is that they will use
next week
the hope among democrats to to introduce
this running mate
and get that person ready for the
following week when they
in essence make their big debut and uh
senator kamala harris's name has been
floated most often
as the front-runner any reason to
believe that's not the case right now
no she definitely remains in the in the
mix as far as we can tell
one one of the more better known uh
battle tested picks on that list given
that she ran herself for president of
course last year
has been elected statewide in the
nation's largest state california
there are of course concerns about the
fact that last summer in that first
debate she went after biden
about his record on bussing and raised
concerns about his civil rights record
generally both say that they've
reconciled since then that they can see
beyond that
but there are a lot of people close to
biden who say that her decision to do
that last summer
is indicative of the possibility that
she wouldn't necessarily be loyal
beyond her of course you're looking at
people like elizabeth warren his former
rival
the obama national security adviser
susan rice and a host of other lawmakers
and governors
lesser known but who have seen their
profiles rise over the last several
weeks as they've been mentioned
okay ed o'keefe thank you very much